speaking of the Great White Hope
what do you think of the president now
he's been almost two years what's your
impression of him today oh it's
embarrassing in what way well all of the
countries that are are traditional
allies uh are no longer even including
the United States and important
conversations because Trump just doesn't
understand anything he embarrasses
himself time and again it's a real you
know it's a it's it's a we the pro this
program is the Fallen State I feel like
the office of the White House is in a
fallen state
and so that's why you say the president
you you don't like it because of the
reason you just gave me no you asked me
how I thought he was doing right give me
something real